all right so some people have told me
that I should talk about the new show
Terra Nova and I I happen to think
they're right so here we go
Terra Nova all right so I've heard about
Terra Nova for months now and I just
heard that it was like one of the most
expensive shows ever made on TV reports
have said that it costs around 20
million dollars which is absurd if it's
not HBO I said Terra Nova starts out in
like the feature 21 50 something I think
and the feature sucks the first shots of
the earth and you're like it looks like
[ __ ] I would never want to live there
you can't even see the ground
it's just smog and wasteland and
overpopulated and so the bean counters
of the feature get the bright idea that
hey if we screwed up here we can go back
65 million years into the past and we'll
just rebuild mankind from there I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
that butterfly effect stuff that we've
heard from other movies they're like
well if you step on a blade of grass 65
million years in the pad you're gonna
change the future like the moon's gonna
blow up or something but they cover
their bases in this one by calling it an
alternate timeline which seems to happen
a lot nowadays it's almost like when
writers found out that you can do like
an alternate timeline kind of thing they
were like oh okay you can have stuff
happen here and it's not really the same
timeline that we came from so you know
we cover our bases like that there's no
paradox so now they're in the past
they've terraforming this little colony
run by Stephen Lang from Avatar and now
we have our show so how is Terra Nova
Terra Nova is pretty interesting but
it's still on Fox and we'll get to that
in a second first when I saw the special
effects I was like it's actually
remarkably impressive especially these
shots in the future like that feature
looks really legit looks like something
might see out of some movies but the
characters are pretty much exactly what
you think they'd be like the main
characters son just cliche teen angst
he's all like you left us for two years
dad I'm sorry dude were you not there
when he punched out the cop to save his
family I don't know in the future they
have population control and they had one
more kid than they should have had so I
decked a cop when they were searching
this place although they're pretty
lenient on the population control laws
because nothing happened to the kid it's
not like they gas chamber to kid or
anything like that so I'm like uh-huh
what's the point they guys slap him on
the wrist like ah you know you shouldn't
do that don't be a fool wrap your tool
it's to save the world the guy's pretty
generic he's kind of like if Kevin
Spacey had a kid with helo from
Battlestar Galactica
he does his job he's supposed to be a
protagonist Steven Lang's character I
like I mean he's pretty much the same
character you played an avatar but a lot
more likable you'll like him but you
don't know if you should trust him cuz
he seems like he has secrets in fact he
does have secrets just
and the first shots to see the dinosaurs
you like oh the Brachiosaurus that's
pretty cool it reminds me of Jurassic
Park for the first dinosaurs you saw
there we're also Brachiosaurus but then
you see other shots of dinosaurs and
you're like they're just not I think
Jurassic Park set the bar so long ago
and just very few things I've ever
broken it I think if you have a movie
about dinosaurs and people that came out
in 1993 they were the first CGI
dinosaurs ever made and then you have a
TV show like Terra Nova that comes out
18 years later I wouldn't expect the 18
year old movie with the first CGI
dinosaurs ever to still hold up but it
does that being said a lot of things
have better dinosaurs in Terra Nova I
don't know if it was the frame rate of
the CGI dinosaurs of the lack of detail
but they just looked like cartoon
dinosaurs and when you have bad looking
cgi dinosaurs in a show that is pretty
much gonna have a lot of CGI dinosaurs
it's probably not a good thing and there
are some intriguing things in the show I
mean who are these Sixers there's a
colony of people who broke off from the
main colony so they're kind of like
renegades but are they actually bad guys
is a pretty intriguing aspect and there
are these weird like chalk drawings on
this rock that looks like mathematics
and geometry and you're like what's that
doing 65 million years in the past that
could be really cool then you find out
what it is you're like oh it's not as
cool as it could have been things like
that kind of ignore me you're like okay
you have this going for you it could be
a really cool thing that really brings
me onto the side of Terra Nova and then
you explain it it's like uh not as cool
Fox is gonna cancel you guys cuz they
cancel everything and that's my main
concern Fox is notorious for cancelling
shows shows that cost a lot less than
Terra Nova so I just don't expect that
it's gonna last I mean look at fringe
fringe is one of the more intriguing
shows on TV now and last year it was
teetering on the line as to whether or
not Fox was gonna renew it for a fourth
season
if fringe was on the line I just don't
know that Terra Nova is gonna pass the
test it being less intriguing than
fringe and more expensive than fringe so
there are things I like about Terra Nova
I like the concept I like the concept of
a shitty feature and people go into the
past and they're gonna terraform the
place and be like alright this is home
now ooh and adventures and dinosaurs and
that sounds awesome on paper but there
was really nothing in the two-hour
premiere that made me go you know what
this is exactly why I need to watch
Terra Nova next week there was no hook
nothing hooked me and in a show that
expensive on a network that cancels less
expensive shows do you need a hook I
enjoyed it but I didn't love it I guess
it would be alright if there was no
competition but it's fall now so all the
shows are coming back so Terra Nova has
some straight-up competition but if
Terra Nova does get cancelled I would
say this
I find network should pick up Tara no
and it would fit him perfectly over
there but I just don't know that they're
gonna have the budget to pull it off so
did you catch terranova what did you
think of terra nova and if you haven't
yet are you gonna start watching terra
nova comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more